El museo Picasso Málaga presenta Picasso escultor, al igual que en el resto de su creación, la escultura de Picasso se distingue por innovar en el uso de técnicas y materiales pocortodoxos. Puedes imaginar cuál es y cómo, descuerela. Estamos entrando en una vez que el caso del caso presenta, el interrubto crea que es una segunda semana. El primer serie de interrubto crea que, Crime Interrupted is returning for a second season. The first series of crime interrupted, researched and written by Vicky Petrados,
马拉加毕加索博物馆举办了“雕塑家毕加索”展览，正如他其他作品一样，毕加索的雕塑以在非常规技术和材料使用上的创新而著称。你能想象出是什么以及如何做到的吗？去探索一下吧。我们正在进入……《犯罪中断》第二季即将回归。由维基·佩特拉多斯（Vicky Petrados）研究并撰写的《犯罪中断》第一季，
dove into some of the biggest cases investigated by the Australian Federal Police, Australia's National Law Enforcement Agency. Season two picks up where season one left off, featuring in-depth interviews with the officers who solved some of the AFP's most challenging cases. Once again, we've been given exclusive access to their case of volt, so you can learn more about fighting crime in Australia at a national level.
深入探讨了澳大利亚联邦警察（澳大利亚国家执法机构）调查的一些重大案件。第二季延续了第一季的内容，对那些侦破了澳大利亚联邦警察最具挑战性案件的警官进行了深度采访。我们再次获得了他们案件档案的独家访问权，让你能更深入地了解澳大利亚国家层面的打击犯罪工作。
The third episode, Operation Blair, has just been released. It follows the AFP as they received intel on a case of foreign bribery that was unfolding in real time. Operation Blair was formed to put an end to the bribery and send a message to all Australian businesses. Pay bribes at your own risk. The first three episodes of Crime Interrupted Season 2 are out now wherever you get your podcasts. All remaining episodes will be released on a monthly schedule. Be sure to hit the follow button so you don't miss each new episode. And if you haven't already heard Season 1, you can go back and listen now. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support,
第三集《布莱尔行动》刚刚发布。它讲述了澳大利亚联邦警察在实时获悉一起正在发生的跨国贿赂案件后的行动。布莱尔行动的成立旨在终结这种贿赂行为，并向所有澳大利亚企业传达一个信息：行贿后果自负。《犯罪中断》第二季的前三集现已在各大播客平台上线。其余剧集将按月发布。请务必点击关注按钮，以免错过每一集新内容。如果你还没听过第一季，现在可以回去补听。我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人不安的事件。如果你在任何时候感到需要支持，
please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on Casefile's Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and add free, you can support case file on your preferred platform.
请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看你所用应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集最初作为付费订阅者的早期福利，发布在Casefile的Patreon、Apple Premium和Spotify Premium频道上。这些剧集设计得稍短一些，使我们能够涵盖更广泛的案件。要提前收听这些剧集并享受无广告体验，你可以在你偏好的平台上支持Casefile。
Well folks, here's my new backyard, said 47-year-old Nadia Medley as she filmed her surroundings with her smartphone. It was Wednesday, May 10, 2017, and Nadia stood alone in the middle of a sprawling paddock on the rural outskirts of Cordewell, Idaho. Nadia slowly panned her phone, capturing the overgrown grass and wildflowers that encircled her. In the distance were trees and the fences of neighboring properties. There wasn't a cloud in the blue sky, and all was silent aside from the gentle sounds
“伙计们，这是我的新后院，”47岁的纳迪亚·梅德利（Nadia Medley）用智能手机拍摄周围环境时说道。那是2017年5月10日，星期三，纳迪亚独自站在爱达荷州考德威尔（Caldwell）农村郊区一片广阔的围场中央。纳迪亚缓慢地转动手机，捕捉着环绕她的杂草和野花。远处是树木和邻近房产的围栏。蓝天上一片云也没有，除了轻柔的
of birds chirping. Kind of liking this just a little bit, Nadia remarked. She honed in on a rundown fence with broken wires that needed fixing. Nadia explained that rebuilding it was one of the projects she had to work on. Add her fate was one of her three pet dogs sniffing and chewing on grass. Dogs are the only thing that's grazing now, Nadia joked, but that will change. The land had so many trees that the house where Nadia lived wasn't visible from where she was standing. The pleasure she took in the peaceful country home
鸟鸣声，四周一片寂静。“有点喜欢这个地方，”纳迪亚评论道。她将镜头对准了一个需要修理的破旧围栏，上面挂着断裂的铁丝。纳迪亚解释说，重建围栏是她必须完成的项目之一。她的三只宠物狗之一正在嗅着并咀嚼草地。“现在只有狗在吃草，”纳迪亚开玩笑说，“但这会改变的。”这片土地树木繁多，以至于纳迪亚居住的房子从她站的地方根本看不见。她对这个宁静乡村家园的喜爱
was evident in her voice as she narrated her video tour of the property. Nadia filmed the farm's henhouse where their chickens were kept, before pausing on a small building further away. Hey Shed, she explained. Yep, baby, we're loving it. Just one week earlier, Nadia had moved to the court well farm from her previous home in the city of Ogden, Utah. She kept her friends back in Utah, wrapped a date on her new life in Idaho via her Facebook page. There, they could watch the video Nadia filmed of her new back yard.
在她介绍房产视频的解说中显而易见。纳迪亚拍摄了农场的鸡舍，随后在远处的一座小建筑前停了下来。“嘿，那是棚屋，”她解释道，“是的，宝贝，我们爱死这里了。”就在一周前，纳迪亚从她之前居住的犹他州奥格登市（Ogden）搬到了考德威尔农场。她通过Facebook页面向留在犹他州的朋友们分享了她在爱达荷州新生活的点滴。在那里，他们可以看到纳迪亚拍摄的新后院视频。
It looks right down your alley, a friend commented. That's so pretty, wrote another. It's a ton of work Nadia admitted, but added that she was loving either her already. A few days later, Nadia posted a photograph of her front yard being pelted with rain during a storm. On Thursday, May 18, one of Nadia's dogs clambered onto a tree with her as she took a break from all the yard work. She shared a photo of this too, writing, this silly dog climbed a tree with us today. A month into her time in Caldwell, Nadia completed a survey of 34 questions about her likes and dislikes. She posted the results to her Facebook page.
“这看起来正合你意，”一位朋友评论道。“太美了，”另一位写道。“这可是项大工程，”纳迪亚承认，但补充说她已经爱上这里了。几天后，纳迪亚发布了一张前院在暴风雨中被雨水冲刷的照片。5月18日星期四，当纳迪亚在繁重的庭院工作中休息时，她的一只狗和她一起爬上了一棵树。她也分享了这张照片，写道：“这只傻狗今天和我们一起爬树了。”搬到考德威尔一个月后，纳迪亚完成了一份关于她喜好和厌恶的34个问题的调查，并将结果发布到了她的Facebook页面上。
Question 25 asked, Are you where you want to be in life? Nadia's answer to this was simply yes. Nadia was originally from Germany. She had immigrated to the United States on her own, where she met and married an American man named Todd Medley. The two worked together in a pet store. They also bred small animals at their home to make extra money. In 2002, the couple had their first child, a girl they named Peyton. Almost a decade later, in 2011, Nadia gave birth to her second child, who died shortly thereafter.
第25个问题问：“你现在的生活是你想要的吗？”纳迪亚的回答很简单：“是的。”纳迪亚来自德国。她独自移民到美国，在那里遇到了美国男子托德·梅德利（Todd Medley）并结婚。两人在一家宠物店一起工作。他们还在家里繁殖小动物来赚取额外收入。2002年，这对夫妇有了第一个孩子，一个名叫佩顿（Peyton）的女孩。近十年后的2011年，纳迪亚生下了第二个孩子，但孩子不久后便夭折了。
Three years later in 2014, while Nadia was still dealing with the loss of her baby, Todd suffered a heart attack and died. With no other family in the United States, apart from Todd's relatives who lived interstate, Nadia and Peyton grew extremely close. They bonded over their love of animals and did fun activities together, such as swimming and picnicking. Nadia described Peyton as one of her favorite people. When two short stories that Peyton had written were published in her school's annual writing anthology, Nadia was incredibly proud.
三年后的2014年，当纳迪亚还在承受失去婴儿的痛苦时，托德心脏病发作去世了。在美国没有其他亲人（除了住在外州的托德的亲戚），纳迪亚和佩顿变得极其亲密。她们因对动物的热爱而建立了深厚的感情，并一起进行游泳和野餐等有趣的活动。纳迪亚形容佩顿是她最喜欢的人之一。当佩顿写的两篇短篇小说发表在学校的年度写作选集中时，纳迪亚感到无比自豪。
Despite her deep connection with her daughter, Nadia still struggled. Utah felt like a strange place to her at times. Nadia loved the state's natural beauty, but as a staunch atheist, she found its overwhelmingly religious culture quite foreign. The headquarters of the Church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day Saints were in Utah, and many of Nadia's neighbors in Ogden were church members. Finances were also a difficulty. Todd hadn't left behind any money when he died, and now Nadia was a sole provider.
尽管与女儿有着深厚的联系，纳迪亚仍然感到挣扎。犹他州有时让她感到陌生。纳迪亚热爱该州的自然美景，但作为一名坚定的无神论者，她觉得当地压倒性的宗教文化非常格格不入。耶稣基督后期圣徒教会（摩门教）的总部就在犹他州，纳迪亚在奥格登的许多邻居都是教会成员。经济也是一个困难。托德去世时没有留下任何钱，现在纳迪亚是唯一的经济支柱。
She began working as a massage therapist at an Ogden Spa. One day in 2015, a man in his late 50s arrived for an appointment. His name was Mike Bollinger, and despite the age difference, Nadia fell to spark right away. Mike was warm and charming with a white smile. Both loved hiking and exploring the great outdoors. Mike was also an atheist, and his values aligned with Nadia's. The two soon began dating. Nadia's friends were thrilled for her. It was clear that Mike had brought happiness back into her life. He was also great with Peyton, sometimes picking her up from school or taking her out for
她开始在奥格登的一家水疗中心担任按摩治疗师。2015年的一天，一位50多岁的男子来预约。他的名字叫迈克·博林格（Mike Bollinger），尽管年龄有差距，纳迪亚还是立刻感受到了火花。迈克热情迷人，有着洁白的笑容。两人都喜欢徒步旅行和探索大自然。迈克也是一名无神论者，他的价值观与纳迪亚一致。两人很快开始约会。纳迪亚的朋友们为她感到高兴。很明显，迈克让她的生活重新焕发了幸福。他对佩顿也很好，有时会去学校接她，或者带她出去吃
lunch. He became something of a father figure, teaching Peyton outdoor skills like shooting or playing with her in the autumn leaves. Peyton seemed to adore Mike almost as much as her mother, and soon she'd started calling him dad. Mike, Nadia and Peyton attended concerts and festivals together, went to the baseball, and hiked and camped in Yellowstone National Park. Because Mike worked as a pilot, he often had to travel for a few days at a time.
午餐。他成了某种父亲形象，教佩顿射击等户外技能，或者在秋叶中陪她玩耍。佩顿似乎像爱她母亲一样爱着迈克，很快她就开始叫他“爸爸”。迈克、纳迪亚和佩顿一起参加音乐会和节日活动，去看棒球比赛，还在黄石国家公园徒步和露营。因为迈克是一名飞行员，他经常需要出差几天。
He made up for his absence by taking Nadia and Peyton on vacations or other adventures that Nadia documented on her Facebook page. By the beginning of 2017, Nadia and Mike had been together for almost 18 months. Things were going so well that Nadia felt ready to ask Mike an awkward question. Her single income wasn't a lot and she was having trouble making her mortgage payments. Nadia had seen Mike's paycheck and knew he made more than $10,000 a month, so she wondered if he might be able to help her out financially. Mike was troubled by the question. He had divorced his wife a decade earlier and an idea was the first woman he'd been involved
他通过带纳迪亚和佩顿去度假或其他冒险来弥补他的缺席，纳迪亚在她的Facebook页面上记录了这些经历。到2017年初，纳迪亚和迈克已经在一起近18个月了。事情进展得非常顺利，以至于纳迪亚觉得可以问迈克一个尴尬的问题。她单薄的收入并不多，支付抵押贷款有困难。纳迪亚看过迈克的工资单，知道他每月收入超过1万美元，所以她想知道他是否能在经济上帮助她。迈克对这个问题感到困扰。他在十年前与妻子离婚，纳迪亚是他此后交往的第一个女人。
with since then. Becoming financially entangled with another seemed far too serious for him and he worried that the relationship was moving more quickly than he was ready for. After a conversation about the matter, the couple broke up. Mike had recently been offered more consistent work based out of Boise, the capital city of Idaho. He'd purchased a rundown farm in the city of Caudwell about 28 miles west of Boise. The property was around one and a half acres and it had a fully equipped farmhouse that was built in 1964. From the outside, it looked like a modest weatherboard home, but it had four bedrooms and two bathrooms as well as a spacious kitchen.
与他人产生经济纠葛对他来说似乎太严重了，他担心这段关系的发展速度超出了他的心理准备。在就此事进行交谈后，两人分手了。迈克最近得到了一份更稳定的工作，基地位于爱达荷州首府博伊西（Boise）。他在博伊西以西约28英里的考德威尔市买下了一个破旧的农场。该房产约1.5英亩，有一栋建于1964年的设备齐全的农舍。从外面看，它看起来像是一栋朴素的木板房，但它有四间卧室、两间浴室以及一个宽敞的厨房。
As he was nearing retirement age, Mike thought the property would be a scenic spot to live out his golden years. The farm needed lots of work, but it was a project Mike was keen to take on. Yet, not having Nadia in his life made Mike realize what he'd be giving up if their relationship didn't progress further. But not having Nadia in his life made Mike realize what he'd be giving up if their relationship didn't progress further. Despite no longer being a couple, they had stayed in touch and still spoke regularly. Both of them missed one another and found being a part very difficult.
随着退休年龄的临近，迈克认为这个地方将是安度晚年的风景胜地。农场需要大量修缮，但这是迈克热衷于承担的项目。然而，生活中没有了纳迪亚，让迈克意识到如果他们的关系不再进一步发展，他将失去什么。但生活中没有了纳迪亚，让迈克意识到如果他们的关系不再进一步发展，他将失去什么。尽管不再是情侣，他们仍保持联系并经常交谈。他们都想念对方，发现分开非常痛苦。
Within a few weeks, they decided to get back together. Proving how serious he was about their relationship, Mike asked Anadia and Peyton to live in Cordwell with him. Nadia accepted his offer. She looked forward to settling in the countryside and starting a new phase of their lives as a family. The setting also suited the animal-loving Pey patron, who would have plenty of room for all her pets, which included dogs, cats, rabbits, chickens, birds, fish, and one snake.
几周内，他们决定复合。为了证明他对这段关系的认真，迈克邀请纳迪亚和佩顿搬到考德威尔和他一起住。纳迪亚接受了他的提议。她期待着在乡村定居，并以家庭的形式开启他们生活的新阶段。这个环境也适合热爱动物的佩顿，她将有足够的空间容纳她所有的宠物，包括狗、猫、兔子、鸡、鸟、鱼和一条蛇。
She and Nadia planned to raise livestock and keep horses on the land. In late March 2017, Nadia shared the news of her upcoming move interstate on Facebook, posting, Here we come. Just over a month later, on Thursday, May 4, 2017, Nadia and Peyton headed north to join Mike in Idaho. With spring in full bloom, the cordwell farm was green and covered in wildflowers. Nadia and Peyton loved it from the moment they arrived. They and Mike spent a lot of time outdoors, working on the repairs that needed to be done
她和纳迪亚计划在土地上饲养牲畜和马匹。2017年3月下旬，纳迪亚在Facebook上分享了她即将搬到外州的消息，写道：“我们来了。”一个多月后，2017年5月4日星期四，纳迪亚和佩顿向北前往爱达荷州与迈克团聚。春天百花齐放，考德威尔农场绿意盎然，开满了野花。纳迪亚和佩顿从到达的那一刻起就爱上了这里。她们和迈克花了很多时间在户外，进行必要的维修工作
around the property. Nadia posted photos and videos of her country life online while encouraging her friends to visit any time. On Friday, June 9, Nadia was scheduled to drive to Utah to pick up some horses for the farm. But she never arrived. Wondering what was going on, the horse sellers tried calling her cell phone. There was no answer. It all seemed a bit strange, but as the sellers didn't know Nadia well, they didn't think much of it. As the sellers didn't know Nadia well, they didn't think much of it. As well as being an enthusiastic social media user, Nadia was reliable and replied to messages quickly.
在房产周围。纳迪亚在网上发布了她乡村生活的照片和视频，并鼓励朋友们随时来访。6月9日星期五，纳迪亚原定开车去犹他州为农场接回一些马匹。但她从未到达。马匹卖家感到奇怪，试图拨打她的手机。无人接听。这一切看起来有点奇怪，但由于卖家不太了解纳迪亚，他们并没有多想。由于卖家不太了解纳迪亚，他们并没有多想。除了是一位热情的社交媒体用户外，纳迪亚还很可靠，回复消息很快。
When her friends stopped hearing from her, they wondered if something was wrong. Peyton's friends noticed that she'd fallen silent too. The last time she'd replied to a text message was on Thursday, June 8. As she was ordinarily glued to her phone, this seemed rather rod. Still, it was the summer, and she'd just moved to a new place, so they wondered if maybe she was just busy working outdoors and caring for her animals. Mike's family hadn't heard from him either.
当她的朋友们不再收到她的消息时，他们怀疑是否出了什么问题。佩顿的朋友们注意到她也沉默了。她最后一次回复短信是在6月8日星期四。由于她通常手机不离手，这显得相当反常。不过，现在是夏天，她刚搬到一个新地方，所以他们想也许她只是忙于户外工作和照顾动物。迈克的家人也没有他的消息。
He had two sons from a previous marriage and neither had spoken to him in days. When more than a week had passed with no word from the cord well farm, authorities were asked to perform a welfare check. Deputies from the county sheriff's department arrived at the property on Monday, June 19. The area was eerily quiet. There was also a foul odor in the air. The deputies entered the farmhouse, calling out to anyone who might be inside,
他与前妻有两个儿子，两人已经好几天没和他说话了。当考德威尔农场那边一周多都没有消息时，当局被要求进行福利检查。县治安官办公室的副警长于6月19日星期一抵达该房产。该地区异常安静。空气中还有一股恶臭。副警长进入农舍，呼喊着可能在里面的人，
but there was no reply. Although there were no people in the house, the deputies did find the bodies of several dead dogs, cats and pet birds. It appeared as though the animals had starved to death. Other pets, including some rabbits and a snake, were still alive. Outside, the deputies checked the handhouse. It was full of dead chickens. They too had apparently died of starvation. Not far from the handhouse was a hayshad. The worst smell seemed to be emanating from there. Inside, the deputies discovered a blue
但没有回应。虽然屋里没有人，但副警长发现了多只死去的狗、猫和宠物鸟的尸体。看起来这些动物是饿死的。其他宠物，包括一些兔子和一条蛇，还活着。在外面，副警长检查了鸡舍。里面全是死鸡。它们显然也是饿死的。离鸡舍不远是一个干草棚。最难闻的气味似乎是从那里散发出来的。在里面，副警长发现了一块蓝色
tarp covering something on the floor. Underneath were the bodies of three people decomposed beyond recognition due to the summer heat. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. If you've listened to Case file before, you've probably heard me talk about SimplySafe. You know they were named best home security of 2023 by US News and World Report, but that doesn't mean they're resting on their laurels. Simply Safe is always innovating and working on the next thing to help keep you and your loved ones safe.
防水布覆盖着地板上的东西。下面是三具尸体，由于夏季高温，尸体已经腐烂到无法辨认。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。如果您以前听过Casefile，您可能听我谈论过SimplySafe。您知道他们被《美国新闻与世界报道》评为2023年最佳家庭安防系统，但这并不意味着他们可以高枕无忧。SimplySafe一直在创新，致力于开发下一代产品，以帮助保护您和您的亲人安全。
Like they're new to in one smoke and CO detector. Its next generation has a detection that distinguishes between fire and cooking smoke, so your home is protected and you get fewer false alarms. The new Smoke and CO detector sensor joins SimplySafe's comprehensive suite of advanced security cameras, sensors and hazard detectors for seamless whole-home monitoring. SimplySafe is designed with cutting edge technology and backed by 24-7 professional monitoring. It's easy to set up yourself, or you can have a certified technician do it for you. With financing available and monitoring services starting from just one dollar a day, there's no reason to wait.
就像他们新的二合一烟雾和一氧化碳探测器。其下一代探测技术可以区分火灾烟雾和烹饪烟雾，因此您的家受到保护，且误报更少。新的烟雾和一氧化碳探测传感器加入了SimplySafe全面的高级安防摄像头、传感器和危险探测器套件，实现无缝的全屋监控。SimplySafe采用尖端技术设计，并有24/7专业监控支持。您可以轻松自行设置，也可以让认证技术人员为您安装。提供融资方案，监控服务每天仅需一美元起，没有理由再等待。
And right now, case file listeners can get 20% off a new system when you sign up for interactive monitoring. Visit simplysafe.com slash case file. That's simplysafe.com slash case file. There's no safe, like simply safe. dejan pensando como por qué los vostezos son contagiosos. Pero MailChimp no. MailChimp analiza los datos de millones de correos electrónicos para ofrecer recomendaciones personalizadas para mejorar el contenido de tus correos electrónicos, segmentar tu público, entre muchas cosas más, adivina menos y vende más con IntuitimailChimp. La marca número 1 en email marketing y automatización.
现在，Casefile的听众在注册互动监控时，购买新系统可享受20%的折扣。请访问simplysafe.com/casefile。即simplysafe.com/casefile。没有比SimplySafe更安全的了。让人思考为什么哈欠会传染。但MailChimp不会。MailChimp分析数百万封电子邮件的数据，提供个性化建议，以改善您的电子邮件内容、细分受众等等。使用Intuit MailChimp，减少猜测，增加销售。电子邮件营销和自动化领域的头号品牌。
Empezado hoy mismo en MailChimp.com. Vas a vender a tus públicos de marcas competidoras en número de globales de clientes en 2020-22. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. When a teacher by the name of Cheryl Baker was in her late 40s, she caught a flight to Alaska and found herself seated next to a very engaging man. Gerald was warm and friendly and the two hid it off. They wound up exchanging phone numbers and began dating when they were both back at home in Utah. In 2010, when Cheryl was 50 and Gerald was 53, they married. Cheryl, who was artistic and creative, made her own wedding dress. The two had a lot in common. Both enjoyed travelling, hiking, and horseback riding.
今天就开始使用MailChimp.com。您将向竞争对手的受众销售，2020-22年全球客户数量领先。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。当一位名叫谢丽尔·贝克（Cheryl Baker）的老师40多岁时，她乘飞机前往阿拉斯加，发现自己坐在一位非常有吸引力的男士旁边。杰拉德（Gerald）热情友好，两人一见如故。他们最终交换了电话号码，并在回到犹他州的家中后开始约会。2010年，当谢丽尔50岁、杰拉德53岁时，他们结婚了。谢丽尔富有艺术感和创造力，亲手制作了自己的婚纱。两人有很多共同点。都喜欢旅行、徒步旅行和骑马。
Cheryl practiced Hinduism and attended the Sri Ganesha Temple of Utah. Gerald took an interest in the faith and would go to the temple with her. He even ended up learning Sanskrit, a classical language of South Asia, so he could better understand the Hindu texts. But the couple had their differences too. Gerald knew a lot about surviving in the wilderness, and would sometimes act as a guide for hunting parties. Cheryl hated guns, and would have to leave the room whenever Gerald returned from one of these trips. She couldn't stand being in the same space while Gerald cleaned his firearms.
谢丽尔信奉印度教，并参加犹他州的斯里加内沙寺（Sri Ganesha Temple）活动。杰拉德对这种信仰产生了兴趣，并会陪她去寺庙。他甚至最终学习了梵语（南亚的一种古典语言），以便更好地理解印度教经文。但这对夫妇也有分歧。杰拉德非常了解如何在荒野中生存，有时会担任狩猎队的向导。谢丽尔讨厌枪支，每当杰拉德从这些旅行中回来时，她都不得不离开房间。她无法忍受在杰拉德清洁枪支时待在同一个空间里。
Overall though, the couple's friends and family were struck by how happy they seemed. In 2016, six years after their wedding, Cheryl and Gerald went on a rafting vacation together. When they returned, Cheryl was glowing as though she'd just been on her honeymoon. She raved about what a wonderful time she and Gerald had together. At around this time, Cheryl was in her late 50s and had been a teacher for almost four decades. In 2017, she toured at Greenwood Charter School in Harrisville, a city just a few miles north of her home in Ogden. Gerald worked as a charter pilot, so he was sometimes away for days at a time, but he'd been offered a more stable job based out of
不过总的来说，这对夫妇的朋友和家人对他们看起来有多幸福感到震惊。2016年，在他们结婚六年后的2016年，谢丽尔和杰拉德一起去漂流度假。当他们回来时，谢丽尔容光焕发，就像刚度完蜜月一样。她对她和杰拉德在一起度过的美好时光赞不绝口。大约在这个时候，谢丽尔已经50多岁，当老师近四十年了。2017年，她在哈里斯维尔（Harrisville）的格林伍德特许学校（Greenwood Charter School）任教，该市位于她奥格登家以北几英里处。杰拉德是一名包机飞行员，所以他有时会离开几天，但他得到了一份更稳定的工作，基地位于
Boise in Idaho. The couple began to think about their future and what they wanted their retirement to look like. They decided to buy a rural property. Bixing it up together would be a fun project after Cheryl left her teaching position in Utah. The couple purchased a farm in the small town of Caudwell on Thursday, May 4, 2017. The plan was for Cheryl to move there right away and start working on things that needed
爱达荷州的博伊西。这对夫妇开始考虑他们的未来以及他们希望退休后的生活是什么样子。他们决定购买一处农村房产。在谢丽尔离开犹他州的教职后，一起修缮它将是一个有趣的项目。这对夫妇于2017年5月4日星期四在考德威尔小镇购买了一个农场。计划是让谢丽尔立即搬到那里，开始处理需要
fixing, such as the plumbing and painting. Meanwhile, Cheryl would keep living at their house in Ogden and get it ready to be sold. The couple stayed in touch during their time apart, and on Saturday June 3, they travelled to New Mexico together to attend the wedding of one of Gerald's relatives. Several days later, on Tuesday June 6, 57-year-old Cheryl worked her final day at the Greenwood Charter School. She was leaving the job to start preparing for her retirement. By this time, Cheryl and Gerald had owned the farm in Caldwell for a month, but she still hadn't seen it in person. Now that she was no longer working, it seemed like the perfect time to surprise Gerald
修理的事情，例如管道和粉刷。与此同时，谢丽尔将继续住在他们奥格登的房子里，并准备将其出售。这对夫妇在分开期间保持联系，并于6月3日星期六一起前往新墨西哥州参加杰拉德一位亲戚的婚礼。几天后，6月6日星期二，57岁的谢丽尔在格林伍德特许学校完成了最后一天的工作。她辞职是为了开始为退休做准备。到这个时候，谢丽尔和杰拉德拥有考德威尔的农场已经一个月了，但她还没有亲眼见过它。既然她不再工作，这似乎是给杰拉德一个惊喜的绝佳时机
within impromptu visit. Cheryl wanted to see the farm for herself and also spend some time with her husband. On Thursday June 8, she let some friends know that she was headed up to the farm. The next time anyone heard from her was several days later on Sunday June 11. One of Cheryl's friends received a strange text message from her. It read, Take care of my dogs, I don't know if I'm coming back. When Cheryl's brother heard about this message, he wasn't concerned.
进行一次即兴访问。谢丽尔想亲自看看农场，也想和丈夫待上一段时间。6月8日星期四，她告诉一些朋友她要前往农场。下一次有人收到她的消息是在几天后的6月11日星期日。谢丽尔的一位朋友收到了她发来的一条奇怪的短信。上面写着：“照顾好我的狗，我不知道我是否会回来。”当谢丽尔的兄弟听到这条消息时，他并不担心。
Cheryl and Gerald loved to travel, so perhaps they went on a last minute camping trip somewhere. But another week went by with no word from the couple. Meanwhile in Coldwell, police had received multiple calls requesting welfare checks on Mike Bollinger and Nadia and Peyton Medley. The three lived on a farmhouse not far out of town and no one had heard from them for 10 days. When deputies arrived at the farm, they were met with a grizzly scene. Multiple pets had died of starvation after being seemingly abandoned. Hidden under a tap in the hayshed were three bodies, believed to be those of the three missing
谢丽尔和杰拉德喜欢旅行，所以也许他们去某个地方进行了一次临时露营旅行。但又过了一周，这对夫妇还是没有消息。与此同时，在考德威尔，警方收到了多个要求对迈克·博林格以及纳迪亚和佩顿·梅德利进行福利检查的电话。这三个人住在城外不远的一处农舍里，已经10天没有人收到他们的消息了。当副警长到达农场时，他们看到了一幕恐怖的场景。多只宠物在被遗弃后饿死了。藏在干草棚里的一块防水布下是三具尸体，据信是那三名失踪者
residents. All had been killed with a single execution-style gunshot to the head. Identification at the scene wasn't possible. The summer heat had sped up the decomposition process considerably, and the trio had likely already been dead for at least a week and a half. One of the bodies appeared to be that of a woman in her late 40s. Another belonged to a teenage girl. It seemed fairly certain they were Nadia and Peyton Medley. But the third body wasn Gerald Michael Bollinger, but he typically went by Mike.
居民。所有人都被一颗行刑式的子弹击中头部身亡。现场无法进行身份识别。夏季的高温大大加快了腐烂过程，这三人很可能已经死亡至少一周半了。其中一具尸体看起来是一名40多岁的女性。另一具属于一名十几岁的女孩。几乎可以肯定她们是纳迪亚和佩顿·梅德利。但第三具尸体不是杰拉德·迈克尔·博林格，但他通常被称为迈克。
Born in Wyoming in 1957, he grew up surrounded by wilderness, which fostered his interest in the outdoors. His family belonged to the Church of Jesus Christ of Valadade Saints, also known as the LDS or Mormon Church. It is a branch of Christianity that was founded in the United States. In 1976, when he was 19 years old, Mike traveled to Manila in the Philippines for his LDS mission. Serving as a missionary is considered a right of passage for young LDS members and is a way for the church to recruit new members all over the world.
1957年出生于怀俄明州，他在荒野中长大，这培养了他对户外的兴趣。他的家人属于耶稣基督后期圣徒教会，也称为LDS或摩门教。这是一个在美国创立的基督教分支。1976年，当他19岁时，迈克前往菲律宾马尼拉执行他的LDS传教任务。担任传教士被认为是年轻LDS成员的成年礼，也是教会招募世界各地新成员的一种方式。
When Mike returned to the United States, he began studying at an LDS college in Idaho, where he met another young church member named Jacqueline Garcia, who went by Jackie. The pair married at the ODS Temple in Salt Lake City, Utah in 1978. Almost immediately, Jackie knew she'd made a terrible mistake. The newlyweds argued a lot, and during one fight, Jackie was sprawled across the floor while Mike loomed over her. Jackie saw how angry he looked and asked, you wanted to hit me didn't you? Mike simply replied, yes.
当迈克回到美国时，他开始在爱达荷州的一所LDS学院学习，在那里他遇到了另一位名叫杰奎琳·加西亚（Jacqueline Garcia，简称杰基）的年轻教会成员。两人于1978年在犹他州盐湖城的LDS圣殿结婚。几乎立刻，杰基就知道她犯了一个可怕的错误。新婚夫妇经常争吵，在一次争吵中，杰基瘫倒在地，而迈克俯视着她。杰基看到他看起来有多愤怒，问道：“你想打我，对吧？”迈克只是回答：“是的。”
Eventually he began acting on this desire and beat Jackie often. At times, she feared Mike was going to kill her. He also regularly cheated on her and lied constantly. Jackie tried everything she could think of to fix things. She contacted Mike's parents to tell them what was going on. She called a domestic violence hotline. She sought couples canceling through the church and sent Mike to therapy aimed at abusive men.
最终，他开始付诸行动，经常殴打杰基。有时，她担心迈克会杀了她。他还经常欺骗她，不断撒谎。杰基尝试了她能想到的一切来解决问题。她联系了迈克的父母告诉他们发生了什么。她拨打了家庭暴力热线。她通过教会寻求夫妻咨询，并将迈克送去接受针对虐待男性的治疗。
But Mike refused to change his behaviour. Eventually, Jackie went to her church bishop and asked for help getting a divorce. A divorce was granted and in 1988 the pair went their separate ways. Jackie was granted sole custody of their two sons, but they still visited their father on occasion. When the boys returned home to Jackie after a stay with their father, the younger one told his mother that Mike had hit him. Jackie called Mike and told him he was not to hit their children.
但迈克拒绝改变他的行为。最终，杰基找到她的教会主教寻求离婚帮助。离婚获准，1988年两人分道扬镳。杰基获得了两个儿子的唯一监护权，但他们偶尔还是会去探望父亲。当孩子们在父亲那里待了一段时间回到杰基身边时，小儿子告诉母亲迈克打了他。杰基打电话给迈克，告诉他不准打他们的孩子。
Mike said nothing, but the next time his son's visited, he sat them both down and said that whatever happened at his house was to stay at his house. was to stay at his house. Not long after he and Jackie were divorced, Mike Bollinger remarried. His second wife was a woman whom he'd been having an affair with. Then, years later, Mike met a teacher named Cheryl Baker on a flight to Alaska. Cheryl had no idea that Mike was already married when they started dating. When his wife found out he was cheating, that married gendered as well. Then Cheryl married Mike in 2010, oblivious to everything that had
迈克什么也没说，但下次儿子们来访时，他让他们俩坐下，说在他家发生的一切都要留在家里。在他和杰基离婚后不久，迈克·博林格再婚了。他的第二任妻子是他一直有染的一名女子。然后，多年后，迈克在飞往阿拉斯加的航班上遇到了一位名叫谢丽尔·贝克的老师。谢丽尔在他们开始约会时根本不知道迈克已经结婚了。当他的妻子发现他出轨时，那段婚姻也结束了。然后谢丽尔在2010年嫁给了迈克，对迈克那边发生的一切一无所知。
been going on at his end. Mike moved into Cheryl's home in Ogden. As far as anyone could tell, they had a very happy relationship. Cheryl never shared any complaints or concerns about Mike at all. Despite his past as a faithful LDS church goer, with Cheryl he embraced Hinduism like she did. Mike travelled a lot for work, but the couple also found plenty of time to enjoy their hobbies together. Then, in 2015, Mike met the recently widowed Nadia Medley at the massage parlour where
迈克搬进了谢丽尔在奥格登的家。据任何人所知，他们的关系非常幸福。谢丽尔从未分享过关于迈克的任何抱怨或担忧。尽管他过去是一名虔诚的LDS教会成员，但和谢丽尔在一起时，他像她一样信奉印度教。迈克经常因工作出差，但这对夫妇也找到了充足的时间一起享受他们的爱好。然后，在2015年，迈克在按摩院遇到了刚丧偶的纳迪亚·梅德利
she worked. Mike then initiated an affair with Nadia. Cheryl's loved ones were adamant that she had no idea Mike was being unfaithful. Nadia's friends were equally certain that her strong morals meant she would never have become involved with the married man. They knew that Mike must have lied about his marital status in order to form a relationship with her. Plus, she had posted openly about her relationship with Mike on Facebook a number of times.
她工作的地方。迈克随后开始与纳迪亚有染。谢丽尔的亲人坚称她根本不知道迈克不忠。纳迪亚的朋友们同样确信，她强烈的道德感意味着她绝不会与已婚男人有染。他们知道迈克一定在婚姻状况上撒了谎，以便与她建立关系。此外，她曾在Facebook上多次公开谈论她与迈克的关系。
If they had been having an affair, surely she wouldn't have done that. Given what a small community Ogden was, it was remarkable that no mutual acquaintances of the two women had seen the posts and said something about the matter. However, it also appeared that Mike and Cheryl weren't social media users. Although Nadia shared photos and videos of Mike, he wasn't tagged in any posts. Only later would it come out that Nadia had mentioned a couple of mild concerns to her friends. She thought it was strange that Mike never stayed over at her place, and she'd only
如果他们有外遇，她肯定不会那样做。考虑到奥格登是一个多么小的社区，令人惊讶的是，这两位女性的共同熟人中没有人看到这些帖子并说些什么。然而，这也表明迈克和谢丽尔不是社交媒体用户。虽然纳迪亚分享了迈克的照片和视频，但他并没有被标记在任何帖子中。直到后来才传出纳迪亚曾向她的朋友提到过一些轻微的担忧。她觉得奇怪的是迈克从不在她家过夜，而且她只
visited his house once. At the time, they put this down to the fact that Mike said it was his first relationship in 10 years. Perhaps he felt shy or thought it wasn't appropriate to stay at Nardias with her teenage daughter in the house. Nardias' house in Ogden was just eight miles away from Sheryls. A couple of years later in early 2017, Mike convinced Sheryl to buy a farm in Cordwell with him, saying it could be their retirement home. Sheryl borrowed money against the house she already owned to finance the purchase, which
去过他家一次。当时，他们把这归因于迈克说这是他10年来第一次恋爱。也许他感到害羞，或者认为在纳迪亚家里有十几岁的女儿的情况下过夜不合适。纳迪亚在奥格登的家离谢丽尔的家只有8英里。几年后的2017年初，迈克说服谢丽尔和他一起在考德威尔买了一个农场，说这可以成为他们的退休家园。谢丽尔以她已经拥有的房子为抵押借钱来资助购买，该房产
was made in her name. The same day that the purchase of the farm was finalized, Nadia and her daughter Peyton moved to Caldwell. Investigators couldn't understand why Mike would move Nadia and Peyton into a home that was owned by his wife, who thought she would be joining him there soon. They wondered if Mike's plan had been to kill Cheryl after using her to buy the cord well property, so he could form a full-time family with Nadia and Peyton.
是以她的名义购买的。农场购买完成的同一天，纳迪亚和她的女儿佩顿搬到了考德威尔。调查人员无法理解为什么迈克会把纳迪亚和佩顿搬进一栋由他妻子拥有的房子里，而他妻子以为她很快就会搬去和他住在一起。他们想知道迈克的计划是否是在利用谢丽尔买下考德威尔的房产后杀掉她，这样他就可以和纳迪亚及佩顿组成一个全职家庭。
Perhaps when Cheryl had decided to make an unannounced visit, this plan had been foiled. The cord well property was large, but it was an isolated. There was another house about 50 feet away on one side, and a second about 30 feet away. A neighbor said she'd heard what sounded like a woman screaming in the middle of the night, sometime between June 6 and June 10. But she couldn't be sure if it was a person or an animal, so she hadn't reported it to the police.
也许当谢丽尔决定进行一次不速之客的访问时，这个计划就泡汤了。考德威尔的房产很大，但很偏僻。一侧约50英尺处有另一栋房子，第二栋房子约30英尺远。一位邻居说，她在6月6日至6月10日之间的某个深夜听到了听起来像女人尖叫的声音。但她不能确定是人还是动物，所以她没有向警方报告。
Others thought they'd heard gunshots on or around June 10. They hadn't thought anything of it at the time, as it wasn't unusual to hear shooting in the rural area. DNA confirmed that the three bodies found in the farm's hayshared were those of Cheryl Baker and Nadia and Peyton Medley. The last time anyone had heard from Nadia or Peyton was on Thursday June 8, the same day that Cheryl drove to the farm. Detectives suspected that Cheryl had arrived at a time when Mike wasn't around. Finding Nadia there instead, Cheryl began to talk to the other woman, and the two of them
其他人认为他们在6月10日左右听到了枪声。他们当时没多想，因为在农村地区听到枪声并不罕见。DNA证实，在农场干草棚中发现的三具尸体是谢丽尔·贝克以及纳迪亚和佩顿·梅德利。最后一次有人收到纳迪亚或佩顿的消息是在6月8日星期四，也就是谢丽尔开车去农场的那一天。侦探们怀疑谢丽尔到达时迈克不在。发现纳迪亚在那里，谢丽尔开始与那个女人交谈，她们两人
figured out that they had both been manipulated and lied to by the same man. Then Mike returned home and became enraged upon realizing his deceit had been found out. Maybe Cheryl had threatened to divorce him, leaving him with no assets as both property deeds were in her name. He then shot dead all three women, including the teenager who viewed him as a father, to avoid the consequences of his actions. But then there was the strange text message Cheryl had sent to a friend on June 11, asking for them to look after her dogs because she might not return.
发现她们都被同一个男人操纵和欺骗了。然后迈克回到家，意识到他的欺骗行为被发现后变得暴怒。也许谢丽尔威胁要和他离婚，让他一无所有，因为两处房产契约都在她名下。然后他枪杀了所有三名女性，包括那个视他为父亲的青少年，以逃避他行为的后果。但随后谢丽尔在6月11日发给朋友的那条奇怪的短信，要求他们照顾她的狗，因为她可能回不来了。
Investigators believed Mike might have sent this message from Cheryl's phone. The fact that he was nowhere to be found indicated he had gone on the run, and he had a 10-day head start on investigators. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case file to continue to deliver quality content. Mike Bollinger's photograph was shared widely throughout Idaho and Utah in the hope he
调查人员认为迈克可能用谢丽尔的手机发送了这条信息。他无处可寻的事实表明他已经潜逃，并且他在调查人员面前有10天的领先优势。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。迈克·博林格的照片在爱达荷州和犹他州广泛传播，希望他
might be recognized. He was 60 years old, 140 pounds, and 6'1 with grey hair and brown eyes. Soon, tips were flooding in from people who had seen him. On Saturday, June 10, Mike had breakfast in Nampa, a city just 10 miles southeast of Caldwell. Then he drove his pickup truck all the way back to Ogden, Utah. He went to a local dealership where a 2007 Ford Focus that he and Cheryl had owned was being serviced. Mike picked up the car and began to drive it instead of his truck.
可能会被认出来。他60岁，140磅，6英尺1英寸高，灰发棕眼。很快，来自见过他的人的线索如潮水般涌来。6月10日星期六，迈克在考德威尔东南仅10英里的南帕（Nampa）吃了早餐。然后他开车一路回到犹他州奥格登。他去了一家当地的经销商处，那里正在维修他和谢丽尔拥有的一辆2007年福特福克斯。迈克取回了车，开始开它，而不是他的皮卡车。
On either June 11 or June 12, a surveillance camera in Swan Valley, Idaho, captured Mike entering the city. He had driven back to the state he had fled. The day after that, another surveillance camera caught the moment that Mike paid an entrance fee to the Bridget-Teton National Forest, located east of Idaho in Wyoming. East of Idaho in Wyoming. The Bridger Teton National Forest is a 3.4 million acre forest that sprawls across Western Wyoming. It sits adjacent to the Grand Teton and Yellowstone National Parks and is a haven for outdoor
在6月11日或6月12日，爱达荷州天鹅谷（Swan Valley）的一个监控摄像头拍到了迈克进入该市。他开车回到了他逃离的州。第二天，另一个监控摄像头拍到了迈克支付进入布里杰-提顿国家森林（Bridger-Teton National Forest）门票的瞬间，该森林位于爱达荷州东部的怀俄明州。位于爱达荷州东部的怀俄明州。布里杰-提顿国家森林是一个340万英亩的森林，横跨怀俄明州西部。它毗邻大提顿和黄石国家公园，是户外运动爱好者的天堂
enthusiasts who love camping and hiking. On Wednesday, July 12, approximately one month after the triple homicide, Mike Bollinger's 2007 Ford Focus was discovered parked at the Forest's Pacific Creek Campground. It was a remote campsite, and it seemed the car had been left there for some time. Investigators were aware that Mike was a competent outdoorsman who would have no issues with trekking into the nearby wilderness. His experience as a pilot might have meant he was also familiar with the forest from the air. Law enforcement used police dogs, infrared technology and helicopters to scour the area.
喜欢露营和徒步旅行的人。7月12日星期三，即三起凶杀案发生约一个月后，迈克·博林格的2007年福特福克斯被发现停在森林的太平洋溪露营地（Pacific Creek Campground）。这是一个偏远的露营地，看起来车已经在那里停了一段时间了。调查人员知道迈克是一个能干的户外运动者，在附近的荒野中跋涉对他来说没有问题。他作为飞行员的经历可能意味着他也从空中熟悉这片森林。执法部门使用警犬、红外技术和直升机搜查该地区。
It was difficult to rain to navigate on foot due to the rocky ground and thick vegetation. Because Mike was considered armed and dangerous, searches were on higher alert the entire time, just in case he tried to ambush them. Local communities and subdivisions were also checked, as were abandoned farmhouses. But no trace of Mike Bologna was found. One week after the Ford Focus was discovered, park rangers in nearby Yellowstone National Parks spotted an SUV being driven by a light-haired man. The vehicle was similar to the sort law enforcement thought Mike might have acquired if he'd left to Bridgetietan National Forest.
由于岩石地面和茂密的植被，步行导航非常困难。因为迈克被认为持有武器且危险，搜查人员全程处于高度戒备状态，以防他试图伏击他们。当地社区和分区也进行了检查，废弃的农舍也进行了检查。但没有发现迈克·博林格的踪迹。福特福克斯被发现一周后，附近黄石国家公园的公园管理员发现一辆SUV由一名浅色头发的男子驾驶。这辆车类似于执法部门认为迈克如果离开布里杰-提顿国家森林可能获得的车辆。
Two Ranges pursued the SUV in two separate vehicles, forcing the driver to pull over. Also in the car was a woman and a seven-year-old girl. The rangers blocked in the vehicle and soon more law enforcement officers arrived. After about an hour, they permitted the driver to show them his identification. His name was Brett. The passengers in the car were his wife and daughter and they were on vacation from Missouri. The officers explained that they were looking for a wanted killer and showed Brett a photograph of Mike Bollinger. Brett couldn't see any resemblance except that they both had a light grey hair.
两名管理员在两辆不同的车里追赶这辆SUV，迫使司机靠边停车。车里还有一名妇女和一个7岁的女孩。管理员封锁了车辆，很快更多的执法人员赶到。大约一小时后，他们允许司机向他们出示身份证件。他的名字叫布雷特（Brett）。车里的乘客是他的妻子和女儿，他们是从密苏里州来度假的。警官们解释说他们正在寻找一名通缉杀手，并向布雷特展示了迈克·博林格的照片。布雷特看不出有什么相似之处，除了他们都有浅灰色的头发。
The family were permitted to leave. News later broke that they were planning to sue the officers, alleging that they had held them at gunpoint for an hour with no explanation. Other sightings of the wanted fugitive continued to trickle in. Someone thought they'd seen Mike driving in Salt Lake City. After Mike's Ford was found, a river guide in Idaho spotted some man by Henry's fork, a tributary of the Snake River. The guide thought the man were behaving suspiciously.
这家人获准离开。后来有消息传出，他们计划起诉这些警官，声称警官在没有任何解释的情况下用枪指着他们长达一小时。关于这名通缉逃犯的其他目击报告陆续传来。有人以为在盐湖城看到了迈克开车。在迈克的福特车被发现后，一名爱达荷州的河流向导在蛇河的支流亨利福克附近发现了一个男人。向导认为那个男人的行为很可疑。
One of them looked like Mike. None of these sightings could be confirmed. Investigators considered the possibility that Mike had taken his own life somewhere deep in the forest. However, they wondered why he would travel so far from home in the days after the murders if he'd planned on killing himself. Why not do so at the farm back in Cordewell? Perhaps he had hitched a ride with another car out of the forest and left his Ford focus
其中一人看起来像迈克。但这些目击事件都无法得到证实。调查人员考虑了迈克可能在森林深处自杀的可能性。然而，他们感到困惑的是，如果他计划自杀，为什么在谋杀案发生后的几天里要跑得离家那么远？为什么不在科德韦尔的农场里做呢？也许他搭了别人的车离开了森林，把他的福特福克斯留在了那里，
abandoned there to shake the police off his tail. In an interview with newspaper The Idaho Statemen, Mike's first wife, Jackie Garcia, described Mike as a prolific liar and possibly a sociopath. Another person who knew Mike but wished to remain anonymous agreed. Quote, if you know about sociopaths, you know they're unlikely to kill themselves. He would have to feel guilty, and he doesn't have a conscience. A friend of Nadia Medley also spoke to the newspaper, saying she felt Mike was too ego-tistical to take his own life.
以此来甩掉警察的追踪。在接受《爱达荷政治家报》采访时，迈克的第一任妻子杰基·加西亚形容迈克是一个惯犯，甚至可能是一个反社会人格者。另一位认识迈克但希望保持匿名的人也表示同意。他说：“如果你了解反社会人格者，你就知道他们不太可能自杀。他必须感到内疚，但他没有良心。”纳迪亚·梅德利的另一位朋友也对该报表示，她觉得迈克太自负了，不会自杀。
In late 2017, a family was hiking in Bridgeteet on National Forest near the Pacific Creek Campground. They came across a junction where two trails met. Standing there was a disheveled man who looked to be in his early 60s. He was alone and looked ill-equipped to be hiking in winter. He had no backpack, water or safety protection, and his face was very weathered. The man passed by the family and kept his head down the entire time. When investigators heard about the interaction, they suspected the man could have been Mike
2017年底，一家人在太平洋溪露营地附近的布里杰-提顿国家森林徒步旅行。他们来到了一条两条小径交汇的路口。站在那里的是一个衣衫褴褛的男人，看起来60岁出头。他独自一人，看起来装备不足，不适合在冬天徒步旅行。他没有背包、水或安全防护装备，脸部饱经风霜。那个男人从这家人身边经过，全程低着头。当调查人员听说这次互动时，他们怀疑那个人可能是迈克·
Ballinger. Months went by with no further developments in the case. Then in mid-2018, a gun was found in Pacific Creek. It was closer to Yellowstone National Park than the Bridgetete on Forest, and was fully loaded. Investigators wondered if it belonged to Mike, but it was in good condition and didn't look as though it had been exposed to the elements. More than a year after the murders in August 2018, authorities regrouped and carried out
巴林格。几个月过去了，案件没有任何进展。然后在2018年中期，在太平洋溪发现了一把枪。它比布里杰-提顿国家森林更靠近黄石国家公园，而且子弹已上膛。调查人员怀疑它是否属于迈克，但它状况良好，看起来并没有暴露在自然环境中。在2018年8月谋杀案发生一年多后，当局重新集结并进行了
another search of the Briditteiton forest. Roughly 20 investigators from multiple agencies split into four groups to cover a four-mile radius of wilderness north of the Pacific Crate Campground. They started at the junction where a family had spotted a suspicious looking man at the end of 2017. Kadava dogs went with them. If Mike was still in the forest, investigators doubted that he was still alive. It had snowed towards the end of 2017, and the snow line was right by the Pacific Creek
对布里杰-提顿森林的另一次搜查。来自多个机构的大约20名调查人员分成四组，覆盖了太平洋溪露营地以北四英里半径的荒野。他们从2017年底一家人发现可疑男子的路口开始搜查。搜救犬也随行。如果迈克还在森林里，调查人员怀疑他是否还活着。2017年底曾下过雪，雪线就在太平洋溪
campground. Mike would have had to survive a bitterly cold winter without any proper gear or provisions. Even for an experienced hunter and guide like him, that would have been extremely difficult. The forest was also home to grizzly bears, wolves and mountain lions. If Mike hadn't taken his own life for diet from the elements, there was
露营地附近。迈克必须在没有任何适当装备或补给的情况下度过严寒的冬天。即使对于像他这样经验丰富的猎人和向导来说，这也极其困难。森林里还有灰熊、狼和美洲狮。如果迈克没有自杀或死于恶劣天气，那么
every possibility that he'd been killed by a predatory animal. Searchers didn't recover Mike's remains, however, they did find some other kind of evidence. They wouldn't say publicly what this evidence was, but they told the media it indicated Mike had never left the forest and had died in there. They put out a bulletin advising people visiting the forest throughout the summer and fall to keep an eye out for anything that looked like scutted clothing or human remains. If Mike had died during the winter, then wildlife would have scavenged his remains when the snow thawed.
他很有可能被掠食性动物杀死了。搜寻人员没有找到迈克的遗骸，但他们确实发现了一些其他证据。他们没有公开这些证据是什么，但他们告诉媒体，这表明迈克从未离开过森林，并死在了那里。他们发布了一份公告，建议整个夏天和秋天去森林游玩的人留意任何看起来像破旧衣物或人类遗骸的东西。如果迈克在冬天死亡，那么当雪融化时，野生动物就会清理他的遗骸。
Nothing of significance was ever recovered. Enough evidence was found in Mike's abandoned Ford Focus and at both of his properties, to confirm he was responsible for killing Cheryl Nadia and Peyton. Detectives have not publicly disclosed what that evidence is. Mike Bullinger has formally been charged with three counts of first-degree murder, yet as of late 2022, law enforcement remains confident that he is no longer alive. Mike Bollinger was described as a chameleon who could mold himself to be whatever a particular
没有发现任何有价值的东西。在迈克被遗弃的福特福克斯车内以及他的两处房产中发现的证据足以证实他对谢丽尔、纳迪亚和佩顿的死负责。侦探们尚未公开披露这些证据是什么。迈克·巴林格已被正式指控犯有三项一级谋杀罪，但截至2022年底，执法部门仍确信他已经不在人世。迈克·巴林格被形容为变色龙，可以把自己塑造成任何特定
woman wanted. With his first wife Jackie, he was an LDS churchgoer like she was. When he met Cheryl, he began attending a Hindu temple with her and even learnt Sanskrit. Then with Nadia, who was an avowed atheist, he said he didn't believe in God either. Those who met Mike described him as warm and charming. He had a charismatic personality and was romantically involved with many women. Someone did if he had found another woman to con and was living in hiding with her somewhere. Others speculated that maybe Mike had used his pilot's license to fly out of the country and start a new life overseas, though no evidence has been found to support this.
女性想要的样子。和第一任妻子杰基在一起时，他像她一样是耶稣基督后期圣徒教会的信徒。当他遇到谢丽尔时，他开始和她一起去印度教寺庙，甚至学习了梵语。后来和公开的无神论者纳迪亚在一起时，他说他也不相信上帝。那些见过迈克的人形容他热情而迷人。他性格富有魅力，与许多女性有过浪漫关系。有人怀疑他是否找到了另一个女人来欺骗，并和她躲在某个地方生活。其他人推测，也许迈克利用他的飞行员执照飞出了国境，在海外开始了新的生活，尽管没有证据支持这一点。
Cheryl Baker is remembered as a kind, gentle and creative woman, as well as an excellent teacher. For over 30 years, she worked at the Utah School for the Deaf and Blind, teaching children with hearing impairments. Sometimes, she bought school supplies and clothing for students who couldn't afford them, and she also searched for funding grants for the school. In 2011, her hard work was recognised when she was awarded teacher of the year by the
谢丽尔·贝克被人们铭记为一位善良、温柔、有创造力的女性，也是一位优秀的老师。30多年来，她在犹他州聋盲学校工作，教导有听力障碍的孩子。有时，她会为买不起学习用品和衣服的学生购买这些物品，她还为学校寻找资助。2011年，她的辛勤工作得到了认可，被评为年度教师。
University of Utah College of Education. Her final job at Greenwood Charter School saw her teaching art classes. This was a perfect fit for Cheryl, who was a talented artist herself. At the Utah School for the Deaf and Blind, a memorial bench has been installed in Cheryl's honor. Two months after the murders, Nadia Medellis' brother-in-law, Mark Medellis, visited the farmhouse where she and Peyton were killed. He had to sort through their personal belongings and found the ordeal very upsetting.
犹他大学教育学院。她在格林伍德特许学校的最后一份工作是教艺术课。这非常适合谢丽尔，她本人也是一位才华横溢的艺术家。在犹他州聋盲学校，人们安装了一张纪念长椅以纪念谢丽尔。谋杀案发生两个月后，纳迪亚·梅德利的姐夫马克·梅德利参观了她和佩顿被杀的农舍。他不得不整理她们的私人物品，并发现这段经历非常令人痛苦。
Mark has described Nadia as independent and stoic, with the deeply nurturing side. This side was most evident when she was caring for her many pets and in house she was raising her daughter, Peyton. When Nadia and Peyton were killed, Mark Madley had been in the process of rebuilding his relationship with them. He lived in to stay but had recently been getting to know his niece, Bedar, via phone calls and emails. In one interview, he stated, It felt like Peyton and I were just starting to get to know each other, and then this happens. It's a hard pill to swallow. Peyton had her own YouTube channel where she posted videos about her life.
马克形容纳迪亚独立而坚忍，有着深沉的母性一面。当她照顾她的许多宠物以及抚养女儿佩顿时，这一面最为明显。当纳迪亚和佩顿被杀时，马克·梅德利正在重建与她们的关系。他住在外地，但最近一直通过电话和电子邮件了解他的侄女佩顿。在一次采访中，他说：“感觉佩顿和我才刚刚开始了解彼此，然后就发生了这种事。这很难接受。”佩顿有自己的YouTube频道，她在上面发布关于她生活的视频。
In one, she painted her mother's face blue and purple with glitter to resemble the galaxy. In her final video, which was posted around in New Year's of 2017, she talked about how she wanted to do things that would make her happy and encourage the viewers to do the same. Do something that will impact your life for the better. Don't just wait for the right moment because guess what? There will never be a right moment. We don't have enough time in this world
在其中一个视频里，她把母亲的脸涂成蓝色和紫色，并加上亮片，看起来像银河系。在她2017年新年左右发布的最后一个视频中，她谈到了她想做让自己快乐的事情，并鼓励观众也这样做。“做一些能让你的生活变得更好的事情。不要只是等待合适的时机，因为猜猜怎么着？永远不会有合适的时机。在这个世界上，我们没有足够的时间
to just keep waiting for the right moment because eventually we'll just give up what we wanted to do once he important will loss the interest and we'll just live our lives not knowing, you know, that we did that. We'll just live our lives and the what ifs. And that's not okay. You need to put yourself out there because we have one shorting life. And no matter what you believe happens afterwards. We have one life and you need to live it the way you want to. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
去一直等待合适的时机，因为最终我们会放弃我们想做的事情，一旦失去兴趣，我们就会在不知道的情况下过完一生。我们只会带着‘如果当初……会怎样’的遗憾过完一生。那是不对的。你需要勇敢地去尝试，因为我们只有短暂的一生。无论你相信死后会发生什么，我们只有这一生，你需要按照你想要的方式去生活。”目前该剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。